well you all know women have your rights
when Taliban came to Afghanistan what
you don't know is Afghan women had their
rights before European women even knew
what that was you know American woman
even knew that a very sophisticated
country in that sense that women were
working shoulder-to-shoulder with men
and women they're working nightclubs
women you know there's picture I've seen
my mom and her friends wearing high
boots and miniskirts dancing you know
we're going to work with the beautiful
suits you know above the knee skirts
high heels the country went like 500
years backwards that's the part that was
really extremely upsetting for Afghan
women because if you've never seen
independence and freedom and you it
doesn't hit you so hard that somebody
suppresses you a little bit further but
if you had complete freedom and it's
come in and it's all taken from you it
is a shock that it's extremely difficult
to absorb and but it was beyond that for
me when I looked at my country at that
time
Azana I wish you know Sarah saw one of
her own
oh man organic barrage of resna edema
doctora well but sure them Theodore well
again I can make nano so Mia had on
August oh that I watch Pomona I'm a poor
man nice George is born with fish no
Mira beef any sin Nicki Matt Marquez's
Megan math gorgeous oh no no worry for
me lawless Oh was I know about the Hana
machine and McCrory O'Connor and
Jonathan chepa holla
today slowly and slowly in Afghanistan I
mean in Kabul I should say and this
suburbs are still very difficult but in
Kabul it's changing a little bit but
once you go to a shock like that a lot
of media asked me a lot about you know
well are you working on getting the
burkas off their women and my answer to
that is the the last thing that an
Afghan woman is thinking about right now
is that she have a burqa on or off she's
worried about her life about her safety
about her family's safety
she's poverty is in the highest level
right now she just cares about building
a fire making some rice and feeding her
family the priority of having her burka
off Iran is not on top of her agenda
what we need to do for women in
Afghanistan is education education
education so they can stand up for
themselves and and when I'm in
Afghanistan I've never worn a burka my
mother never won a burqa neither my
grandmother so it's not something I've
ever seen before I shot the movie I made
a statement about it I just refused to
dress like that I wanted to be one
person has to start you know be the
example of saying it's okay you know
look at me okay so I have I have a
little scar sometimes was on sometimes
was off I wasn't so paying attention to
it covering my face and all that all the
time and yes I got some looks but I
didn't care about it I just said you
know deal with it I'm not gonna do it
I was a school
it's yes to me hon come on you know push
the fish Paula bro
nay nay I look like a fish in the sea
c'mon whatever Tony can map in it huh
second father on me for me is like Jeff
has some of that free class was Vikram
all together be short fat Magnum like my
- I solve a thorough job - she don't
want again I show family behind Jarrod
Caribbean jihad not react attack very
actionable push yourself Enomoto mother
goes tapas Namira for midi producer
Samba react Sonia metalic model ship
available at satsang mom Myron I push my
pasta Hodja past Nevada Mottram Navajo -
no sir